ruby grimm eclipse is a bad license
video game not because it's a bad game
although it certainly is but because it
doesn't take any of the positive
qualities of the show it's based on sure
it looks like the show features the same
music and voice actors makes the
occasional callback but it lacks any of
its clever writing charm and personality
if there's one thing I expected this
game to get right it would have been
those things because of Ruby Grimm
Eclipse is a very unique example because
it was created in-house at roosterteeth
the same company responsible for the
show so rarely does a show have such
direct access to the talent behind the
show which based on and even with all
that advantage the game barely makes an
effort from a clip starts off with a
pretty solid premise by being a
four-player hack and slash action game
the style of gameplay lends itself well
to letting players mimic move fast and
stylish combat that's core to the show
but the game likes the budget
productions to be the Bayonetta like
that it needs to be sword instead ghost
with a simpler approach invoking dynasty
warriors instead which is perfectly
alright as long as the game still fun to
play it's fine it's not though each
chapter has you run through a linear
level fighting enemies with the
occasional dialogue and that's kind of
AIT's the environments while
nice-looking are large and empty you run
through these massive areas simply to
get to the next group of enemies to
fight and the time in between fights is
dull and boring and that's really all
you do is stop to fight enemies and then
move on sometimes it'll mix things up by
introducing a wave of enemies and then
another wave of enemies oh and what's
that over there
it's another wave of enemies sometimes
waves happen while you must defend an
objective however this objective takes
so little damage it might as well not
even be there it's not until halfway
through that something finally new
happens with this car escort mission but
it's not very fun and I rather go back
to the waves there's simply not enough
variety to the missions that by the end
of the second level you feel like you've
seen everything the game has to offer
because you kind of have the combat
itself isn't great either there isn't
really much in the way of combos so you
just kind of have to run up and spam the
buttons and hope you
except even that doesn't really work
enemies have this amazing ability to
block all your attacks which isn't
telegraphed well enough in the chaos in
battle so you'll be wailing on them for
a few seconds before you realize you
aren't actually doing any damage and
some of the systems feel like they're
really clashing against each other
rather than working together take these
enemies that you encounter around
halfway through they explode after
hitting them so the idea is you want to
hit them then dodge away or shoot them
from a distance but the game also says
hey you can counter these guys so you do
it because there's a button prompt and
the game says so and why not is the
game's telling you to do it
however this moves you right on top of
them guaranteeing that you'll be hit by
their explosion so your reward for using
the counter system is taking damage the
game also lacks any real tutorial which
at first seems fine since everything is
so basic you can pick up on the
mechanics just from playing at least
that's what I thought until I encounter
this ability on the skill tree which
describes a cool move your character can
do but doesn't tell you how to pull it
off after going through most of the game
not understanding how to activate the
skill I finally found it by looking up a
user made steam guide outside of the
game I'll repeat that a user guide not
found in the game turns out this whole
thing is related to team attacks to do a
team attack you must get an enemy in a
state where they can be attacked by your
teammates which is symbolized by this
silver icon above their head how do you
get them in the state it's completely
random once they're in this state
another teammate will see the icon in
bronze and then can run up and hit the
right bumper and do that special move
completing a team attack again none of
this is explained in the game at all as
I mentioned earlier it's the ties to the
show that really make this disappointing
the narrative holding these chapters
together is paper-thin
a small dialogue telling you where you
are and what your objective is but none
of it is particularly interesting the
first half has you running through an
uninspired retread of locations from the
show which is cool to see but offers
nothing new with them while the second
half does offer brand new places and
enemies they aren't particularly
interesting the attempts to develop a
more concrete narrative with brand new
characters comes in very late and falls
completely flat because it lacks any of
the punch from the original show and
dialogue delivery that is shockingly
poor
No how could I be so stupid initiating
the upload you did it
now can you proxy decision closes your
school prepare to meet your doom some of
the characters personalities do slip
through with the occasional line but
these moments are few and far between
the campaign ran me about three hours
and considering it stopped being fun
after the second level probably a good
thing the game does encourage you to
play again this time with a different
character but even if that was something
I wanted to do which it's not the
characters simply don't feel different
enough from each other to feel like I'm
getting a different experience if I
sound like I'm being overly harsh it's
because honestly I had pretty decent
expectations for this I'm a fan of the
show I think it would make a great video
game and there's a lot of potential
there this game squanders all of that
it's hard for me to even recommend the
most die-hard of Ruby fans who would be
okay with a somewhat mediocre game but
they get to hear some funny dialogue
considering the game's incredibly steep
$25 price points that's really who this
is for fans of the show and I think it's
such a missed opportunity that they
couldn't even capitalize on that
considering they had such direct access
to the creator's themselves hey
everybody thanks for watching this video
if you have been playing the game or
you're a fan of the show please let me
know in the comments below start a
conversation I enjoy having those with
people if you want to see more stuff
like this I hit that subscribe button it
really helps sound tells us that people
like this stuff and hey have a good day
better and better better and better
better and better better and better
better yeah oh yeah oh yeah better and
better better and better
booyah booyah booyah booyah booyah
booyah booyah booyah booyah booyah
booyah